[Music]
whoa whoa whoa
this week we've got car vending machine
and an unfortunate tweet take it away
Tiffany I'm an unfortunate tweet sounds
boring I want a more quick rate
I want this [ __ ] Drive Toyota machine
hi what was the first car vending
machine you did the opposite nevermind
take your away Tiffany so does launching
in the sky it's gonna explode yeah
remember Japan and all those little
[ __ ] things that they had all over
the place yeah everywhere yes I'm
disappointed to find out that I was the
majority of them were just drinks I'm
like how often yeah but you will never
go thirsty in Japan if you only have a
few coins to thinking doesn't bring big
money thinking gosh gosh gosh gosh
please I'm fine thank you oh my gosh so
for our first story we have what has
been dubbed the world's largest luxury
car vending machine in Singapore yep so
it's 16 story okay okay
what would you think it was I thought it
was a Carlos trying to go ride a vending
we should attach to it
exactly that's cool though y'all think
you are so down because I thought you
drive by the yo let me should drag it it
stopped when you put the way to 15 it's
a 15 stolen ice cream truck to me I know
I even have a distinguishing I think
because we're just kind of tie it so you
don't even gotta toss to a car salesman
it's 15 story 50 stars a 60 slot so you
just slide in your card and then boom
the car comes out you got a pocket
nobody well I'm not sure exactly how it
works I was trying to find out like we
better get [ __ ] out I couldn't
anywhere online so feisty this morning
and I long for the people I'm gonna show
you guys a video clip of it little bit
realistic whoa that's a big ass bending
machine first of all these are not way
cars this is not a miniature City
why does though Transformers the music
doesn't make any sense that the world's
largest military car vending machine the
world is going to end the aliens will
attack you could do nothing this is the
autobahn motors building in Singapore
lease Veronica Clara's that we're
getting squash them or if you think I'm
playing a video game
[Music]
you get to push a button and it rotates
Lipa that's what I wanted to find out
like how actually worked pretty good
elevator yeah the rest of my videos in
getting this [ __ ] today if I was the
Joker I would try to find a way to steal
the whole building and carry it off in a
helicopter how I just figure I don't
know I [ __ ] go to the floor and then
unbolt the parts are attached to the
floor hire some crazy ass [ __ ]
helicopter you probably like ten
helicopters I like how in your mind it's
just a full structure and this is all it
is it fell down by horrible no
helicopters gonna go literally this is
for imagination I haven't seen the
blueprints so I'm just going with the
most because it's a contra not an
architect you I should only help with
the blue drill yep do that dull I wonder
if you could like there's an elevator
for every single floor and you just walk
up and you can look at the car now so
the way they actually have it so they
have it like an advanced vehicle
retrieving system like so advanced to
the point where there's multiple
companies approaching them wanting to
buy the technology right right to
partner up with them so then they can
have it in like certain parking lot
well there's already a car missing that
means some people bought a car maybe is
this like a vending machine where you
put the money in and then enojado you
hit like a 1 and in that bottle like
[Music]
Bueller I want out every sculpted
Ferrari you put it and it's like
the guy's finger for Helena happened
I want the Lambo right I wish God did
I'd be crying the [ __ ] up I wanted to
find out how to actually worse than I
did see that there are other kart car
vending machines here in the US what and
they actually had like a big coin that
you put into like a very really where so
how does it work they have to buy from
an actual salesman and then they get the
coin and then they put the coin it's
ridiculous you lost me because I was
imagining somebody with the [ __ ] ten
bags of coins just sitting there I was
imagining somebody was a black card and
they just like swipe it in and that
makes more stuff that makes much that
yeah those car vending machines that I
saw here they had like actual why they
trying to go back in time I just know it
what's up one of them also you know how
to Singapore they're very limited with
land so that's why with this company the
audubon motors they this dealership they
ran out of space and they have so much
demand for so many more cars that they
don't have enough room to likely all out
on a lot so they develop this they want
to be you know very like technologically
advanced agreement I see so that is you
so instead of like you know when you go
to like a car dealership if they don't
have the car you want they got to go to
the storage lot and it's like hella
packed tight yeah they got to move like
four or five cars out before they can
move this one this one they all kind of
just move independently exact I'll help
this concer comment' the [ __ ] car
salesman talk [ __ ] that's really [ __ ]
annoying hold on let me talk to my
matter you ain't talking to nobody [ __ ]
I know for a fact you going back there
you have a copy and chillin and you
can't wait my out so wait me out they
always do that [ __ ] they try to wait you
out the whole time I'm not talking to
anybody no you know what you should do
well next time you buy a car Vic I'll be
right back I need to talk to my sister
they just balance and then you just go
I'll talk to my wife manager while you
talk to your manager yes like that
simple thing we should just go sit in
your own heart look at him while you're
drinking we're like to be on that doing
anything you told officer da ville'
right with you I need a break from this
deal too let's just hang out in the
break room yeah b-boying in the middle
of the second place [ __ ] you know is
dope we bought her car we went to the
dealership and there's only 30 minutes
left
to open and I think they're trying to
get the [ __ ] out dude we made the whole
deal happen in like 30 minutes
on three minutes up to close and only
meant those supposed to like close at
nine we went to that like 8:30 so what
we were planning on buying so that's
what you got to do it's going to the
dealership at 8:30
we should go just cut them out yeah like
literally five is plenty close the same
thing actually doing all that because if
you take a look at card you know what
are the [ __ ] one kind of hungry I was
probably dinner god damn it right next
sorry
you guys remember Michelle Kwan on your
smarts cousin yeah is not cool on ya if
Michelle Kwan Korean or Chinese Chinese
Chinese rule F of Z so Kwan kwo n is
Korean and kwa and is Chinese there to
keep centre culture in the English
depends on des
if they know grammar because my family
there's three spellings for her last
name there's people with GU a n
depending when they came is the Keeler
San Francisco l1 yeah there's another
guy there's another person with qu a n
so it's just Harvard whenever you go to
the immigration how does that white guy
wants to spell your name that's the name
you get stuck with kwa we all have the
same last name with our Chinese
character but in English there's three
different spellings yep yes how about
pron was that Tron Tron yeah so Michelle
Kwan is being reported that she found
out about her divorce her husband
through Twitter oh she doesn't speak to
her husband I didn't even know she was
married I think that's the point
how old is she no 14 D is 36 okay
oh wow she's really actually been
killing up with that long what she's 36
she color young so she
Olympics when she was like young yeah I
like 15 or some shift in cuz I thought
she was like a 90 sensation god yeah
yeah I remember from childhood but she
just wanted at that young holy [ __ ] does
Michelle with her like a Y relation I
can't tell why I think actually I don't
do it mixed you name is clave towels
okay so her name is Michelle pal
so Michelle pale okay sound effects a
pal - she changed her last name Alex ah
that's true I don't know either because
they still refer to as Michelle Kwan run
she's royalty that's why one do that
Club so what did she do she popped open
Twitter one day she's sipping on her
coffee and then he's like oh by the way
I'm divorced puts it up I found it on
Twitter Peter they have been having
marital problems for a while and stuff
sucks as I was getting around that's why
should be meeting around themselves
punished a lot of you know the ones you
got bucketheads baby that's fascist Nazi
you keep your [ __ ] heads together so
they don't get dizzy yeah well not work
it is not work I do faster oh no are
busy Salinas are those bins to [ __ ]
head whipping I had been having marital
problems to say they like moved away
from each other for some time to get
like some space and then they started
working things out and then they that's
when out of the blue she just saw that
tweet that her husband had filed for
divorce behind her back what a loser
that's because you married a [ __ ] he's
a lawyer too did I he hired a celebrity
lawyer and he was expecting Michelle to
pay for his fees ladies don't marry a
[ __ ] for a man what is it sir
before they get me a marker that cannot
confront a [ __ ] that can't speak
is mine hmm a [ __ ] that can't
say what he really wants to do that is a
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] for
you can you don't mean it out hammock
before you tell your your wife so that's
what they keep mentioning I don't know
what it was referring to I don't know
who tweeted it there's I've been
searching for I can't find it so I don't
know who tweeted it or if he even was
involved in it look he moves it he moved
it out that's what he didn't believe in
it
well I do know that the next day I do
know that I'm believe it was the next
day is when she saw an article written
about this on Bailey's Daviess out she's
like what the [ __ ] man I'm finding all
this [ __ ] about my marriage before me
like what the hell like that so now
she's trying to dismiss the because her
husband filed for divorce in California
but she's trying to dismiss that case
and get divorced in Rhode Island which
is where they live together you know
what the cool thing is though Michelle
Kwan's II you my friend are still young
you got time plenty of years of [ __ ]
plenty or more years for marriage you're
not old
you're fine you're okay and you got
Asian genes he was old as [ __ ] you look
great you still look the same as when
you did when you're 12 today instead it
yeah yeah still got that prominent
Chinese nose this should still escape I
wouldn't she show that leaves
rollerblade
you know rollerblading and ice skating
it's not the same thing it's way
different people tell me that [ __ ]
they told me that [ __ ] but it's just
like rollerblading bitch-ass [ __ ]
liars are individually ice skating
actually this way harder do it is not
the same and when you're heavier you put
a deeper line so if you [ __ ] the person
behind you that's pretty great there's
no socks and ice skating but it's all
falling down yeah and those people who
do the hard stuff and they [ __ ] spray
ice everywhere those [ __ ]
all right fine maybe you're so cool oh
you mean there's no standing still
no there's no stopping at all don't stop
there's no break there's just you just
keep going if you do the hard stuff yeah
I don't know how to do that I'll just
fall for him
yeah secant for beginners there's no
stopping and you could do that [ __ ]
key thing but that's just slowing down
when you put your back leg like this and
you it's like ah while you're crashing
into the wall yeah I'm gonna try that
would you be the one to wear butt pads
when you ice skate there's what pads I
just I wish nobody they like imma do it
but I just time it so I just you know
how you going to Lukey Luke
so you just speed up and then you just
slow down and when you want to stop you
just eventually slowly get to the wall
then you start grabbing the wall and you
go like this or you get the one where
it's like the old person Walker I mean
that I can't like go along I have too
many pride for that so I just bought my
face Tuesday thanks for watching just
kidding you guys don't forget to comment
down below we want to hear what you say
only its positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby
[Music]